[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Well, happy
Thursday, everybody.
Welcome to the Data
Science Hangout.
If this is your first time
joining us here today,
it's so nice to meet you.
Thanks for spending
your Thursday with us.
I'm actually calling in
from the Posit Office.
Nobody's here with me today,
but I have this nice
view of the water.
But if we haven't met
yet, I'm Rachael Dempsey.
I host the Data Science Hangout
and lead customer marketing at Posit.
This is our open space
to chat about data science leadership,
questions you're facing,
and getting to hear about
what's going on in the world of
data across many
different industries.
And so we're here the
same space, same time, every Thursday.
So if you're watching
this recording on YouTube later,
you can add it to
your calendar with the details below.
But together,
we're all dedicated to making
this a welcoming community for
everybody. And so we love
hearing from everyone,
no matter your years
of experience, titles,
industry, or even
languages that you work in.
So every week,
I'm joined by a different
leader here from our community
who joins us to share their
experience and answer questions from you all.
So to let you know how to
ask questions, first of all,
it's totally OK to just
listen in if you want to.
But there's also three
ways you can jump in
to ask questions.
So you can raise your hand on
Zoom, and I'll be here looking out.
You can put questions
in the Zoom chat.
And feel free to just put a
little star next to it if you
want me to read it. Or else,
I can call on you to
ask the question live.
And then lastly, we
have a Slido link,
which Tyler will
share here in--
when I said that--
thanks, Tyler--
where you can ask
questions anonymously too.
Well, with all of that,
thank you so much for
joining us here today.
And I'm so excited to be joined
by my co-host, Mike Lopez.
So Mike is senior director of
data and analytics at the NFL,
National Football League.
And Mike, I'd love to have
you introduce yourself,
maybe tell us something you
like to do outside of work too,
and share a little
bit about your role.
- Thanks, Rachael.
And thanks to everyone to
Posit for organizing this.
It is an exciting time
to be in football data.
And we just have a lot of
questions that we have to try and use
naive or advanced models for
because there is so much about
the world of football that
we are just starting to learn.
My background was, I was
a high school teacher, turned
PhD student, turned assistant
professor at college.
And at that point,
the influx of football
data became apparent.
The league started
getting Next Gen Stats,
which is each player wears a pair
of RFID chips in their shoulder pads.
And you went from an NFL
data history where every game had
160 plays, so 160 rows of data,
which everyone was analyzing
locally on their laptops to
now, a world where we have
this tracking data, both
RFID-based and then now even
video-based. And it's just hard--
there's just a lot that we
are learning and trying to figure
out. So my job is to organize
a group of really intelligent
young data scientists that
are helping us and helping the
league make better decisions.
- Awesome. Thanks, Mike.
And something you like to
do outside of work too. [LAUGHS]
- Out of work. Our preseason
starts tonight. And
I now realize that from now
until the end of March, most of
my spare time is going to
be keeping an eye on what happens
and everything
related to the NFL.
So I got my--
my spare time was over the
summer. I have three young kids,
and so hanging out with them is
really how I spend my spare time.
But tonight,
that is now done with an eye
on the NFL game that's on the television.
- So watching football, is
what you do in your spare time?
- Yeah.
It's
a nice side gig.
- That's great. Well, Mike,
I know there'll be a lot
of questions coming in from
everybody shortly here.
But just hearing that initially about
how you're using data from the RFID
tags on the players,
I'd love to just understand a
little bit more about what that
process looks like and how you
ingest that data, what
you do with that data?
Just walking me through a
little bit of that process.
- So the league has, I
would say, two data warehouses of
systems of storing
data. In the early 2000,
that's when the league
initially started building a
lot of the SQL server that the clubs
still use and that we would still use.
That would be your
traditional game stats.
So if you play
fantasy football,
the yards caught by a wide
receiver, or the quarterbacks
yards per game, or
whatever that would be,
that would be your
traditional game stats.
In 2015 was when
the league first--
it might have been '14 or
'15. I wasn't with the
league at that point.
But that's when the league
started collecting the player tracking data.
And they had seen it catch
on in other sports and it was
driven by the media
group out in Los Angeles.
And so if the
game stats are
stored in New York,
the media data is stored
and managed by Zebra,
and the Next Gen
Stats team out in LA,
we ingest it.
There are a couple of ways
that the league gets it.
One is using an API.
The second is there is a
SQL server that now is dedicated to
organizing and
managing that data.
One of the unique things about
the tracking data is that it
really changes your data
pipeline and how you organize
and manage your code because
you used to be able to
just load every NFL game
play-by-play, whatever it has, and
analyze it, fit a model,
make a graph. Now, you have
to be a little bit more
articulate about how
you're doing that--
I don't know if articulate
is the right word.
But you have to
be a little bit--
be forward-thinking.
And a lot of times, what we
do is just fit it on a play.
If you want to figure out,
was the wide receiver open?
Don't try to do that on
every play that wide receiver has
ever done. Just try to do it
on one play. And identify a way of
whatever metric you're creating or
looking at openness for that
wide receiver, and
doing it on that play.
And that takes a lot
of time because you're probably the
first person to think about
your level of ranking,
that openness or whatever. And
we're doing a lot of things
at the league to increase the
awareness of football data and to
give people the code so that
they can build their new work
off of it, but it's still new.
And then once you've
done it on that one play,
you then try and
do it at a game.
Try to write a function
to do it on the game.
And then obviously, extract it
to all players and all games.
And all that stuff takes
time. So that's how
the traditional--
you would be an analyst in
the year 2012 or '13, and
you'd download CSVs, and you'd
analyze all the plays at once.
Now you have to be a little
bit more cognizant about how to do
that just because of the
size of the tracking data.
- Thank you. That's
really helpful.
I see a ton of
questions starting to come in here.
Devin, I see you asked one in
the chat. Do you want to jump
in? I can ask the question.
If you want to jump in with
more context, feel free.
But the question was,
what kind of decision-making is
your work driving at the league
level versus the Moneyball
team versus team decision-making?
And Devin said, thanks for
powering my fantasy leagues as well.
- So
we are primarily interested
in what happens on the field.
And if it happens on the field,
we're hoping to measure
it in the sense that--
how close are our games?
How exciting are they?
What are the trends in
how teams are calling plays,
and how players are playing,
and how coaches are coaching?
We do a lot
with our officiating group,
trying to help them
make better decisions.
And then also both the
on-field decisions,
but also the training.
We work with player health and
safety on making sure that the
rules of the game are
the best match between
keeping the players safe,
making sure that their equipment is
as top notch as it can be.
And then also going back to
the rules, like what are the best--
whenever we talk about
a rule of the game, it's
driven by does it make
the game more competitive?
Does it make the game
safer? Can our officials officiate it?
Does it keep the game exciting?
Things like that. So we try
to organize a lot of our support
for the league around a
lot of those questions.
The teams make the decisions
to go for it on fourth down.
They make the decisions
to challenge a play,
to start at quarterback or
to draft a certain player.
But a lot of what we're trying
to help with is that there are
new tools to help
with those decisions.
There's new metrics
that we can help create,
there's new data sets that
we can provide them. And
ultimately, what they do with
it is obviously up to them.
- I know you just touched
upon the health data. But Geraldine,
I saw you had a
question about that.
Do you want to ask
a follow-up there?
- Yeah. Because when
I asked that question,
you were mostly talking about
tactics and plays, et cetera.
So I was wondering,
do you guys also
analyze players'
health stats around things like
whether or not they get
concussions from impacts or
dehydration? Or is there a
separate team that deals with that?
-
So as part of the NFL
collective bargaining agreement
with the Players Association,
the league doesn't analyze
that data themselves,
but there are two
third parties that do.
Two companies that
we work with a lot,
IQVIA and Biacore
are their names.
And they're both really good,
from an epidemiological side
and an engineering side,
at looking at how do we--
what are the
trends in injuries?
What are both rates
of concussions or injuries,
or missed time injuries,
or leg strains?
How have those changed over
time as athletes have gotten
faster and the teams
are passing more? And
things like that.
So those are collaborations
that we're a part of.
The specific raw injury data is
not something we touch on a lot.
Only in the sense that when
it comes time for changing the
punt player, the kickoff play,
or the rules around
how to protect the quarterback,
it's never just a health
and safety question.
It's health and safety and
an officiating question.
And a
competitive question about if this
is going to make our games
closer, or more blow outs,
or less exciting, or less
tradition, things like that.
So a lot of the way that we
try to work with those types of
questions is like,
how does this impact the
entirety of the game? And
the other aspect that I think
is really neat about where
football is now is that
it's not just the game data,
it's also the practice data.
And so
most
clubs have performance
scientists that work with
trainers on managing
player load and
optimizing player
performance from, I think,
both a performance
and an injury side.
And that's not stuff that
we're allowed to help with,
but we do know that a lot
of clubs are going down that route.
- Greg, I see you had
a question in the chat too.
Do you want to jump in here?
- Yeah, sure. Thanks,
Michael for being here today.
I actually got a chance to
see you speak at the University of
Denver back before
the pandemic,
which seems like a lifetime
ago at the Sports Analytics Conference.
So I was just wondering if
you have any thoughts on how transferable
analytics skills--
sports analytics specifically
are across leagues.
If you build up experience
with baseball or basketball,
how does that transfer
to football or other sports?
I know some of them are
more emerging than others.
- I mean, honestly,
I don't think you can
be a great sports data scientist
without really having a sense of
what's going on in other sports.
So I would say, it's
really two-fold. One is
the skills themselves
are transferable.
If you can code tracking
data in football, you
can code it in baseball, you can
code it in basketball, et cetera.
It might take you a little bit of
time to get up to speed, but the specific
functions that you're writing
or the specific ways that
you're transforming
the tracking data into
metrics that you can
communicate with a coach, that
you can do in any sport
once you can do it in one.
The hard part is being
able to do it in one.
So I think that's one area.
And then the second one,
which is really maybe
just as important is,
what are the other sports
doing? What are they looking at?
One recent thing that's
caught on to a lot of folks in
football is that
baseball teams no longer
draft a player and then
send the player out there,
and the player performs
or doesn't perform.
They're now doing things
in training to maximize the
player's launch angle, or their
exit velocity, or their swing
path because they think that they
can take a player and help
them improve using data.
And I don't think football
has always been that way.
I think
maybe corollary would be,
you would have a quarterback
and you'd throw the quarterback
out there, and they'd either
complete the pass or miss it,
and maybe you could get a
new offensive coordinator.
But maybe now, you
could be thinking about,
where is the quarterback
holding the ball?
What is their path to throw it?
Is there something
that we can do that's
maybe the corollary of
a swing in baseball?
So that's one example that
isn't certainly the only example,
but I think it's a combination
of both the hard skills,
hands-on keyboard stuff that
if you can code, you can code.
And if you know sports,
I think that's going
to certainly transfer.
But there's also an awareness
of what are other leagues
doing? What are the metrics
that they've come up with?
I think
it certainly helps on the
data science to have that background
and that skill set because
there's just so much out there
that the NFL can learn
from other sports.
And I do think specifically
given some of the competitions
and the work that the football
has done in the last couple of
years, other sports are now
learning stuff from football too.
- I appreciate that.
Thank you very much.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: Mike,
we talk a lot about
community in the Data Science Hangout.
And I think the Big Data
Bowl is an amazing community
initiative that
stands out to me.
And I was wondering,
do you see this
initiative happening in other
sports or other industries now?
And do you have any tips
for people who are trying to do
something similar?
And it might be helpful to just
explain what the Big Data Bowl is too.
- So
one of my weaknesses
is I hold grudges.
And so I used to always get
a little bit irritated with some well-known
sports, conferences, and
organizations that would
maybe run hackathons or
share data in ways that,
as an academic and as somebody
who supports reproducible
research, maybe didn't
have those same values.
And so when I started at
the league, I was pretty steadfast,
that I thought the league could
do a better job of sharing data.
And one of the ways that
we've done that is through an event
called the Big Data Bowl, and
it has a couple of purposes:
One is let's innovate in
football. And we can be
talented all we want as
a league office and whatnot,
but there's only so much that
our group can do and the Next
Gen Stats group can do. There's
just a lot of other things.
And the idea being that
there's just a lot we can do.
And if you share data,
people analyze it.
So the
quote from Field
of Dreams is,
"If you build it,
they will come."
If you share the data,
they will analyze it,
especially in sports
data. So that's
one of the main
reasons we did it.
We also have the motivation
where we have this complex data
set that no one's
ever looked at,
and at least this was
our initial philosophy in 2018.
And if that's how we feel,
that's also how the
32 NFL teams feel.
And when you work
at a league office,
you're in some ways
employed by the 32 teams.
And so we're doing it for them.
We're doing it to give
them a pipeline of analytics staffers
that they can hire to go
answer their own questions.
And one of the really neat
things is, and I've hinted at
this, is that this
is an opportunity for anyone
to come in and analyze.
And it really levels the
playing field in the sense that
before, when you would hire in
sports data, you
might look at a GPA,
or you might look at where
the person went to college,
or you might look at
maybe where they
interned last summer.
Now, you're looking
at their code.
You're looking at
what they built.
You're looking at what is
their level of thoughtfulness in the
questions and the way
they communicate their results?
Which ultimately,
that's how you're evaluated
when you're on a team.
If you're on a data
science team and that's your job,
is to build interpretable
metrics and to communicate those,
and to do a good
job of validating your models,
and things like that,
that's what the Big
Data Bowl is all about.
So
we've seen a lot of--
one of the neat things is
that now people are copying
football, and that was never
a place where football was before.
There was the Big Data
Derby and horse racing.
There was the Big Data Cup,
which athletes
put on in hockey.
I think there was like now
a fantasy football one.
And it's pretty humbling
to know that that
largely started with the NFL
sharing data and being open
about it. So we're certainly
open to more leagues doing it.
In terms of advice,
the
number one thing that we
found is that the crowdsourced
metrics are always better than
anything we've ever come up
with ourselves. And
the more thoughtful and,
I guess,
thinking forward about
what people will analyze,
I think companies will
get the most out of it.
We've had competitions that
have immediately turned into
metrics that are
shared on air. And
our 2020 competition was on
rushing yards and within maybe
11 months from the
contest ending,
you watched the NFC title game,
which has maybe 30 million
viewers. They're
watching a metric that
came from our competition. And
that's a
really exciting aspect
of that competition.
And so the better
questions you ask,
the better answers you'll get.
But I think overall,
we've certainly found that the
crowdsourced approach has really helped.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY:
That's amazing.
I was just sharing in the chat,
last year's winners actually
spoke at a Posit meetup.
So if anybody wants to save
that and check it out too.
Yue, I see you've had your
hand raised for a bit here.
Do you want to jump in?
- Sure.
Hi, Michael. Thank you
for being here. I have one
question. So what type of data
are you using for the analysis?
Are they tabular structured
data or unstructured data,
like images or recording
from the game directory?
And if the data
are unstructured,
how do you process them before you
can use them for analysis and modeling?
- Good question.
I would say, with
each passing year, we're
getting to more unstructured
data. But I think the league
has done a pretty good job.
And when you're at
a league office,
we have a large number of
data engineers that help--
that ensure our SQL tables are
clean and easy to read from.
I would say, most of
it's pretty structured.
And the other reality is
with player tracking data.
At least in the NFL,
because it's RFID-based, it's very accurate.
And so it's a tabular format.
In fact, if you go to
our Big Data Bowl site,
you can download it as a
CSV. And it's a big data set,
but it comes out clean.
That's not necessarily the case
with maybe some of the newer
data sets we'd be getting
into. If you talk about,
like video tracking,
which would be
taking from an image and then
trying to look at player location.
One of the ways that football
is going is that we have RFID
tags on all 32 NFL teams and
all the players and all the games.
However, those players come
from a pool of college players.
The NFL can't make college
players wear those same RFID tags.
And so when you
want college data,
you either have your
traditional stats or you've got
to use video-based data.
And so a lot of
that video-based data on college players
is stuff that is
a little messier.
And so that would be where
you would have to extract it from
imaging, and things like that.
There are companies
out there that do that.
And
I don't know if
it's an arms race,
but I do know that NFL
teams are really interested in those
skills because
of the way that--
before, you would have to have
a dozen scouts go out and watch
videos of the teams in the
northeast and the southeast
and all over. You'd send
scouts. And teams still do that.
But now, if you can get
some of that insight by
coming up with an algorithm
that can take the data from the
video and turn it into
a nice, usable format,
it can certainly save you some
time and maybe get you some
insight you weren't
getting otherwise.
- I see so many great
questions coming in here.
So I'm just trying just to
sort through some of them. But Lisa,
I see you had a
question a bit earlier
on Mike's transition
from academia to the NFL.
Do you want to jump in?
- Sure.
I'm Lisa.
I was just curious about
how you made the transition from
academia to
working for the NFL and how
you think that academic experience was helpful?
And then maybe, again,
this is probably selfish,
but how did you market
that academic skill set?
- I think the best part about--
the most helpful part about being
in academia is that you are evaluated--
and I was at a small
liberal arts college--
you're evaluated
on your teaching.
So you have to be
a good teacher.
I was a tenure-track
assistant professor, and
evals would come in. And when
you weren't doing a good job,
communicating to your students, that's not--
that's going to ding
you or whatever.
So
I think that's the
most helpful skill set,
is that my job was to take
statistical methods and distill them down
to students who were learning it.
I've been teaching
R for maybe--
or
some software for a decade.
But when you do that in 2020
or whatever, I couldn't be
teaching the same stuff I
was teaching in 2010 because
software was
entirely different.
So you also have
to keep up-to-date.
And that's a lot of what we
do now. Our job is to communicate
statistical results or methods
to folks that aren't statistics
experts. Now instead of
students, now it's executives.
One of the things that we
are constantly working on is,
what do we show? How much is
too much? When do we lose them?
How many plots is
too many plots?
Do they need to know the
ins and outs of our models?
And whereas in when
you're teaching,
you really need to communicate
all the ins and outs.
Certainly, we
don't do that now.
But I think there's a lot of--
the experience that was most
helpful was teaching and
communicating results.
We don't do as much writing.
I don't have as many research
papers maybe as I used to would
have. But now,
for better or for worse,
I spend a lot of time
making presentations.
And I think a lot of that's
the same approach where you're
trying to take what you've
learned and distill it into a
template that others
can understand.
I
started in 2018 when I
worked at the league office, maybe
doing one PowerPoint deck
every couple months. And now,
for better for worse, I just--
I have to do that a lot
because I have a really talented group
of data scientists that are coming
up with so many cool things. And
I am now helping them
curate material to share with executives.
And
like I mentioned at the start, there's
a lot that we can do and
trying to figure out how
to communicate that goes back to
that experience in academia,
where you're writing a journal
article or you're writing
a summary of your
work. So that's
where it's been most valuable.
And I also think
one of the cool aspects about
where we are now is that
there's just still
a lot to learn.
And that's no different than
being in academia where you're
an expert in something and
you're trying to build the next
tool or you're trying to build
the next model or the next paper.
And there's--
I think it's not that--
I like to often refer to our
work as we have a laundry list,
and sometimes our job is
to just start at the top,
what's the most important
thing we can do,
and that's not much different
when you're in academia and
trying to do the same
thing. So great question.
And I don't know if
I answered it right,
but that's what I would think.
- Yeah. That was great. I
took some notes. So thanks.
- Of course.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: Thank you.
Can we stay on this topic
for just a bit here?
When you were saying--
when you were talking about
the communication skills that have
transferred over,
I was curious if you do
have certain tips for us for
communicating to executives or what
you've learned in many of
those presentations
you've given?
- I mean, we've tried
and failed a lot. I mean,
there's things that I've pushed
for or we felt strongly about
that other people
were like, yeah.
And then there's other things
where maybe I didn't feel as
passionate about. And then
suddenly, maybe every--
maybe the presentation got
shared a lot more widely and I
read about it the
next day on espn.com.
So it's hard to really know.
I haven't kept a spreadsheet of
what's worked or what hasn't in
terms of communicating
results. I think
we have to have good
data visualization. If we don't,
we can't do our job.
And
I think I spend probably--
and my team would probably complain
about how I do this. But
I probably complain
about things that I--
if this was a student paper,
I probably wouldn't write because
I have to make sure
that the work that is
being presented is as clear and
concise as it possibly can
be. It can't be confusing.
It has to have the
right annotations.
The stuff that has come out
in ggplot in the last couple of
years and also in gt with the
visualizing the tables has
been really helpful in that
front. Because for a while,
we would have to make tables
in an old school format
or I'd have to add annotations
in PowerPoint because you
couldn't code that.
So that's probably the
most important thing,
is your viz has to be topnotch.
I also--
and this just comes partly from
experience partly because I
played football in college and
my dad was a football coach,
and I grew up watching
way too much film.
But the more closer you are
to the subject level matter,
the better you are at your job.
It doesn't mean that you
need it for all roles.
You can be a great coder and
learn that skill set along the way.
And I mean, football is,
in some sense, a complicated
sport. But in another,
anybody can learn it
if you try to learn it.
So it's not like it's too
far away from somebody to learn.
My mother-in-law complains
that it's too hard to learn.
But I would say, in general,
you can figure this stuff out.
But a lot of the things that
we do is we just answer their questions.
And
I think the
second part of communicating that
result is sometimes we are
answering the questions that
we know they're going to ask
before they've asked
them. And I think
the best presentations we give
are the ones where they're
asking a question and
then just click Next,
and it's on the next slide.
Or they ask a question and
I say, yep, it's in the Appendix.
Click a couple slides
forward and say, here it is.
Because you have to anticipate
the questions they're going to
ask. You have to--
sometimes,
we're collecting data before they've
asked us to collect data
because we can tell--
like we hear something in the
media or we hear something that
they're asking in the replay
room or their coaches are
asking, and we're like,
we're going to go build this.
Because they didn't tell us to
go collect data on quarterback slides,
but we now know that
quarterbacks are sliding more
than ever before.
We know quarterbacks are the
most important position in football.
So last year,
Andrew Patton basically led
an NFL data collection processing
quarterback slides.
Because we knew that when
we got to the offseason,
somebody was going to say, hey,
how are how are quarterbacks
sliding? And it's like,
actually, we have that because
we went out and collected it.
So I would say that it's a
combination of great data viz
and then also being
purposeful and forward-thinking with the
questions that people are
going to be wanting to ask.
- That's great. Thank
you so much, Mike.
Sanjay, I see you had your
hand raised a little bit ago.
Do you want to jump in here?
- Yeah. Hi.
I
was curious when you said RFID
tags were used
to track players.
And so what all the
data do you collect
apart from just tracking the
players? I mean, is that speed,
direction? What all is
captured? Just curious to know.
- So it captures
the x, y-coordinate data, two
dimensional. We don't
get their height.
The tags are like the
size of your thumbnail
and they fit into the
player shoulder pads.
And so the players don't
even know that they're wearing them.
They turn on whenever
they go on the field.
You could watch players on
the sideline if you wanted to.
Wouldn't recommend it.
But
then the league takes that
data, they share. From the x,
y data, we get their speed
acceleration because it's two
chips. We also get
their orientation.
That's all curated and sent out
to the teams from the league office.
So
you could watch NFL and
you'd see fastest players or fastest
acceleration speed.
You could get change of direction
from it without too much effort.
So that's the type of thing
that you would get from this data.
- And do you have an
RFID on the ball also? MIKE LOPEZ
: Yes.
Good question. Yeah,
there's an RFID on the ball.
With players,
I would say it's accurate
usually to within a couple
inches. The ball is maybe--
has a larger margin of error,
maybe closer to
five or six inches.
And then with all of it,
with both the 22 players, the ball,
there's also RFID tags in
things on the sideline like the
pylons and the chains. I don't
think there's much use in
those, but the league
has been collecting it.
And then it's all
at a frames of
10 frames per second.
So
a given a play is seven
seconds long, you're going to get 70
observations of that
player on that play.
And you could animate it
to follow them around.
You also get their data before
the snap and after the snap.
It's just a matter of
what you find most useful.
- Aaron,
I think you had a question
related to that about the ball
too. Do you to jump in
here? I think the question
was about officiating.
And let's see. Aaron said,
I've always wondered why can't a
tracker be placed on the ball
to determine when it crosses the
plane for a first down or touchdown?
So is that something
that's being looked at?
- And I think Geraldine's
question is similar.
It is being looked at.
There are a couple of differences
that I think matter a lot.
One is, NFL stadiums are
enormous and there's a lot of
player overlap on
almost every play.
And so the cameras have
to be further away,
unlike tennis where
they're right on the field.
And unlike maybe a VAR decision
in soccer where there's two or
three players maybe
right in a tight space,
arguably there a lot more.
So the technology that you can
see in other sports is a little
bit more complex to
apply to football. In my
now six years,
there have been
several attempts,
some gaining more traction than
others to do video-based spotting.
It is a challenge.
And
the current accuracy margin of
error of the football itself
using the chip in the
middle of the ball can't
replace
the on-field spotting for
a couple of reasons. One,
I mentioned the
margin of error.
If you're saying
the ball is here,
but then you look on the
film and it's actually here,
it's really difficult to justify
that to a viewer at home,
why you're making a first down decision
or a decision on the goal line.
And I think the second
part there too is the
ball spotting process in the NFL is
based on the tip of the football.
Without
totally changing the construct of
the chip in the football,
we don't know that, and the
chip is in the middle of football.
It's been tried to
put multiple chips in,
then you're messing around with
the mechanics of how that feels
to the quarterback. And
we don't want to do that.
So there are
video-based attempts,
that my intuition is
within a couple of years,
there will be use cases of
it that you'll see on air where
the technology is helping the
process of spotting the football.
But it's not as easy as
maybe it appears in the other sports.
And I also think
the other aspect for us is
that pace of play is really important
in the sense that tennis can
have a break or soccer can have
a break to look
at this decision,
and maybe the ball
isn't in play.
The second the ball is put
down, the ball is in play.
Other than the couple stoppages
for replay or in between downs,
in between a fourth down
and a punt play or whatever,
there's no
example of saying, pause, hold
on, we're all going to wait.
We just don't have that time.
Coaches want the ball to move.
We want the game to
be three hours or so.
And that continued
focus means, sure,
there might be a tool out there
that's going to get us the
exact right spot. But if
it takes three minutes, that's not
a trade-off I think the
league would be making.
- Thank you.
I see Jared had a question, and
you put the star next to it.
So I'll read it.
But Jared asked,
how does someone get into the
NFL space as a data scientist
to help improve player
safety and performance?
- So I think there's a couple
of ways. One is, I mean, there
are--
I mentioned IQVIA and Biacore,
but they are two companies
we work with a lot.
And they're
specifically targeting
things like the epidemiology
of injuries, return to play,
injury trends based on
how teams are playing.
The equipment, safest
helmets, safest cleats,
safest shoulder pads, or
the characteristics within a
play that the orientation of
player
limbs that could
lead to injury.
So I think there are things
that are specific to the injury
side of things that
are part of it.
Then there's also the maybe
more performance side,
which is all the teams
want those same questions answered.
And they have--
just like you see the Next
Gen Stats player tracking data in games,
they get catapulted in practice
or there are other companies
besides catapult
that do it does it.
But catapult is probably
the biggest one.
So you have the same data that you
get on your own players in practice. Now,
that's not data that the
league office would get.
But if you're on a team
and you could identify, like listen,
this player has had two or
three really hard days in a
row, maybe that comes
with an increased injury,
risk of a hamstring strain
or something. I'm just--
I'm not necessarily making
that up, but that's hypothetical.
So those would be the things
that you would get into,
is thinking along like,
what happens within a practice?
And how to make sure that
that player that put forth a certain
load, that traveled
a certain distance,
that ran at his
high speed for 10
minutes, which is maybe
a lot, or three minutes,
which maybe isn't a lot,
how are they going to
perform the next day?
Because ultimately,
the job of teams is to
win games and you win games when
your players are healthy.
So the coaches understand
the value of this too.
So it's a league level basis.
But then also on a
more micro level,
the teams are also
looking into it.
- Thank you. Nick,
I see your hand was raised
just a few seconds ago.
Do you want to jump in here?
- Yeah. Sorry. Sure.
Coming up in here. Hi,
everybody. Nice to talk to you.
So my question revolved around,
I guess, communication
of what you're finding and just having
some a personal feel and read on football
personnel and staff.
So I know a lot of the
old guard guys might be--
and folks in general might
be a little bit resistant to
analytics and just the
philosophy. So I was wondering--
and I know you mentioned
you're doing more PowerPoint
presentations and
talking to people.
How are you getting people to
buy into analytics as a
whole? How can you take
the modeling that's the math
and turn it into actual advice,
but also from a
perspective that is
digestible for football
coaches, or personnel,
or whoever might be working
with you in a way that they can
use it, accept it, and
feel better about it?
Because around the
football space,
it seems like the word
analytics is a little bit like
a stink on it, if
you know what I mean.
- I haven't had a
lot of pushback.
I've been here six years.
There's not been a
single meeting where somebody was
like, I don't want
to see your results,
or I don't care about
y, x, or z. I mean,
I mentioned earlier that there
are certainly times where I've
thought the league maybe could
have done this or a certain
team could have said, hey,
we think we should
prioritize this more,
and maybe that hasn't happened.
I think a lot of
it comes back to,
we're not trying to answer
different questions that they are.
We're trying to answer the same
question they are and we're
trying to put numbers to it.
And
there are lots of examples where
we just get a sense of
the questions that they're
after, what they're interested
in. And we say, here's
what we're thinking.
And I also think
I think we do an appropriate
job pushing where we need to
push and then also
saying sometimes, listen, I mean,
there are a couple examples
of random projections we've been
working on in the last week
where sometimes we've just said honestly,
we're giving you a projection
for something for some time.
But I wouldn't even
really trust it.
I personally don't trust our
own model because there's too
many uncertainties that--
too much noise in the system.
So I think we're also--
we try to balance
when we push.
And
one of the advises I got
from somebody, I think,
in hockey a couple
of years ago is--
I was asking that person
why their team didn't do something.
And it was like, OK--
in hockey,
it was a specific thing that I
thought teams could do to gain an edge.
And their point was, this
analysts that I talked to, is
that they look at their role
as they have a certain amount of
times that they could really
push. And sometimes, you do it.
And sometimes, you say, listen,
I think my team probably could
increase my chances of winning by this,
but there's something else that comes with
it that maybe I don't want to--
it's not necessarily--
it moves the needle only this
much and it's not worth it.
So I do think our team also
tries to be a little bit
purposeful with how we balance
when we are saying, like, hey,
this is something we should
change or this is something we
should do because we only
get so many cracks at it. And
there are times
where I think hey,
we could really improve
our decision-making here.
And there are other times
where I would say, hey, listen,
I can give you a number,
but go with your gut.
It's probably not going
to be that far off.
So
I think our team is
pretty smart about adding all the
caveats and the
stars to say, hey--
the asterisk--
like hey, take our results
with a grain of salt.
So many things are happening
in football. Teams are changing,
the rules are changing that.
Assuming that maybe this is going
to hold or that this is
the best way to do it
is not right. But then other times,
we try to really push for
things. So it's a balance of that. RACHAEL
DEMPSEY: That's really
helpful feedback.
Listening to all the
different pieces of
data you're working with
or problems you're looking at
solving, even some things that
people haven't asked for yet,
how do you prioritize what
your team is working on?
- I don't have a
great answer there.
A lot of it is honestly--
we
have a meeting in a week
or so with some executives.
And my last slide is, here are
six things we can do this fall.
Tell me where you would
prefer we spend our time.
So maybe that's part of this,
is just getting a read on it.
We're not totally obtuse to what
we hear in the media in
terms of what people are
talking about because if clubs--
it's a weird--
it's weird to be
in a public-facing industry.
But if clubs leak it to
some media organization,
it's a non-zero chance.
It makes it way
back to our group.
If you're familiar
with football,
one of the things that
last year started early in the
season is teams would do what's
called a push quarterback
sneak, where you would
have quarterback line up.
And traditionally, they
would sneak forward. Now,
you put somebody behind him and
two or three people are pushing.
So similarly, quarterback
slide process, we were like,
let's collect this data because
we saw it on ProFootballTalk in
week 2 or 3. And it's like,
if we don't collect it,
they're going to get to the
end of the year and complain about
it. And it's going
to be like, oh, crap,
we should have measured
this. So it's like, OK,
now we got to measure it.
So it's just being in tune
with what's out there,
what we're seeing on the field.
I mentioned--
I know, Rachael, you asked--
what I like to do for fun.
I watch football for fun.
But I also watch it knowing
that whenever something
happens, like sometimes,
there's going to be a question
we need answer on Monday
morning. How often does this
happen? Is this getting worse?
And addressing that.
We deal with a good number of
questions from the clubs and from teams.
Sometimes from an
education perspective,
but then also sometimes from a
complaint perspective where
they think they're being--
there's a perceived
slide against them. So
just trying to be a little
bit aware of what's going on.
And for us, honestly,
that's just paying
attention and watching. RACHAEL
DEMPSEY: Thank you. Kayla,
I see you had a question a
bit earlier as well about the types
of tools they use. Do
you want to jump in here?
- Sure. Yeah, I think I
asked a question about,
if most of this work is
done in Python and R,
are there any particular
packages if so,
or if that goes
mostly internal?
Or if there's any other
software typically used in NFL
sports analytics?
- A great--
good question.
I would say, we're more on the
R than the Python side, but it's
a decent mix.
I've asked this to NFL
team staffers. And one other, I
think, good point that just
exists is that teams are
hiring more and more,
so there's more and more folks
with our Python backgrounds going to teams.
When I started, I want to say,
that there were maybe 70
or so data scientists.
Data scientists being a
catch-all term here.
Folks that were using football data to
try and help the team on the field.
Maybe 70 or so.
And I think the most
recent list is we're somewhere around
130 or 140. So within
the last five years,
teams have basically doubled
their infrastructure on the
football data side.
And of that group, being familiar
with a lot of them, our
team probably knows
the majority of those folks,
I'd probably put it about
70-30 R versus Python.
And that's probably where
our team sits internally.
Certainly, there are--
I think right now,
most postings are like
have to know R or Python.
A good number of managers are
probably more comfortable in R because of
where football data has been,
but that doesn't necessarily
mean that it's any better.
And then I also think there's
a growing number of roles for
people that know neither, but
know what football data is.
And this would be
your communicator type role.
So folks that maybe are
really up-to-date with current
football metrics and maybe
have coaching experience or playing
experience, and they want
to be the translator.
They want to be the person that
is going and saying, hey, I
can't fit that
neural net model,
but I know you can and I know
what it's going to give me as a
result. And this is, I think,
what's going to help this coach
or this assistant GM or whatever.
So I would even say,
there's even a good amount
of room in football analytics for
non-coders. People who
have some ability to know
what's going on in the
background, know a little
bit about modeling,
and know what the strengths
and weaknesses are,
while maybe not being able to
do it on player tracking data,
but also having that ability.
You really have to know
football to get into that role,
and not every team has them.
But if you stay up-to-date on
the Big Data Bowl and on Next
Gen Stats and on
public-facing research,
you can provide a lot of
value to your team in terms of
identifying trends that are
meaningful and maybe trends
that you would want to ignore. RACHAEL
DEMPSEY: That's really cool. What
would that role be,
the translator?
- I mean, if--
so for example,
you're an offensive coordinator
for a team and you want to
build a scouting report,
you want to build a
dashboard that says,
here's what the opposing defense
is going to do each week,
there are lots of data
scientists that could do that.
A good number of them,
especially the ones that have
spent the last four or five
years in football tracking data
might not know the names that
your team is using for what
that opposing defense is
running. They might be able
to separate man from zone coverage,
but they might not be able to separate
cover 2 from cover 4 from cover 6.
Or they might not be
able to understand the strong side
linebacker for the
weak side linebacker.
And so now, you need
somebody to say,
OK, this is what the
coach is looking for,
this is what this term is,
this is what this blitz is.
And then your job is to code
it all and to work with that
communicator to help that.
- I guess I was just curious,
like what that title is?
How do people find those roles?
-
A lot of them would just
be analysts or even quality control coach.
Seth Walder from ESPN on
Twitter has a really good link.
I'm sure somebody can find
it and put it in the chat.
All sports analytics
careers are like this.
There's a bunch of different names for
people that are doing the same stuff.
And it's weird.
My title is director or senior
director of football data and analytics.
I could be senior director of
football analytics research or a senior data--
probably not a senior
data scientist anymore because I
don't code as much. But
some are analysts, some are
data scientists, some are whatever.
And
there's not exactly one perfect
name for it, but it's probably
an analyst type of role.
But it is, a lot
of times, like--
football coaches know a lot,
and they're using data
even if they're not
telling you they're using data.
They're
going to tell you that they're
going to target the left
cornerback on the other team
because they turn their hips
too early. Well,
you could probably use an
analyst to go figure out when
they turn their hips too
early, what does that mean?
And so a lot of times,
you're just trying to communicate to be
that line. Because
unfortunately or fortunately,
that offensive coordinator
might not have all the time in
the world for this
person to advise them on it.
So that's where you need
some of the translators. RACHAEL
DEMPSEY: Well,
thank you.
George, I see you had a
question in the chat a few
minutes ago. Do you
want to jump in?
- Yeah, thanks.
So I was just wondering--
this is something I
always think about whenever I'm
watching a sporting event--
is
how do I get
my organization to
report at the level of
what I see the NFL or
ESPN or any in-game commentator reporting on?
The, kind of, analytics that
come out of their mouths,
I'm just in awe of. And
it's historical. Sometimes, it's like, well,
the last quarterback who did this
was in 1978 and he had
blonde hair and went to
this college. And I'm like,
I mean, first of all,
I don't even think that's relevant.
But the fact that they could
pull that out of nowhere in 10
seconds is pretty impressive.
I've tried doing that in
my field in HR in the past,
and there's always the bar that
I have. But I'm just curious,
how does one go about even
trying to achieve that level of analytics?
- It's almost like
a research team.
And the NFL does have
a research team that
before every game, they provide
the media with an enormous--
basically like a folder
of all the things.
And this is automatically
generated using various tools
of all the things that
are applicable to these teams.
And it's almost like scouting reports
that you would see of a
baseball player or
a football player.
And so when a wide
receiver catches the ball,
the commentator is able to go
and say, Oh, this is interesting. He
caught the
highest red zone target rate
of any tight end last year.
And a lot of it's not
because they've done it.
It's because somebody
has handed that to them.
We don't do a lot with it.
That's maybe certainly
more on the media side.
But I do know that
that's the research.
A media team's job is to prep
basically a portfolio for them to pull from.
And I do think one of
the things that they're balancing is,
how do I take a lot of the
new metrics that nobody's ever
heard of? Versus some
of the old things,
like everybody knows what a
blonde hair is. That they could--
you could pull from that that
maybe wouldn't make as much sense.
So
that's where, I think,
football data is now is how
much is too much and what
is a reasonable thing
to give our audience?
Maybe an area we don't
deal as much with,
but it is relevant to some
of the research they get.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: I realize
I missed a question over on
Slido. So I want to make
sure I get to some of the--
one of the anonymous
ones. But it was--
you're going to have to help
me with this acronym. Does gait, G-A-I-T,
analysis of the players
have any impact on their
performance?
And what are the KPIs that
you generally look for for a
player's potential impact?
- So
we've tended to stay away
from some of the performance metrics.
And I think that's what G-A-I-T would be.
And so I wouldn't be able
to know as much there. I think
the weird angle we would
come at performance would be like,
how does the league set
policies or rules for a
schedule or for practices that
allow players to reach some
level of performance?
So we've done a lot
of research on, for example,
what is the impact of playing a
team that just had a bye week
the previous week? Each team
gets one bye week a season.
If you're the Jets and
you're playing the Giants,
and the Giants have had
two weeks of practice,
what type of advantage does
that provide you on the field?
So it's a different
performance angle.
And the other ones would
be like back-to-back-to-back road games or
travel
advantages. That's a different
type of performance thing,
but I think that's probably the
closest to the thing that the
league could control. Ultimately, for
a lot of legal reasons,
we're not as in tune with some
of the performance stuff on the team side
at least the league office.
But I do know the
teams are obviously interested in it.
- Well, thank you.
Brittany, I don't think we
got to your question yet.
Do you want to jump in here?
I think you had a--
oh, you unmuted.
I'll have you ask it.
- Yeah. So
I know that with the
introduction of the RFID tags,
I'm sure that there's
a bunch of new data points
that you're exploring that
previously haven't been
explored. But also,
I'm sure that there are maybe
changes to rules of thumb or
heuristics or around already
existing data points that maybe
are coming into play now that you
have a little bit more specific data.
Can you talk through how
you've been evangelizing those new and/or
maybe different than expected
things and how you've been
getting buy-in from your
business partners around that? MIKE LOPEZ
: Good question.
And I can share a
little bit of this
because they shared it this
past offseason. But one area was--
stuff I was just mentioning is
that we did a lot of research
on what I would call
scheduling inequities and
basically how things that the
league sets impact game outcomes.
And there were a good
number of surprising ones,
where things that I think
most people would perceive as having
a big impact on a team's chance
of winning the game maybe
didn't matter as much. And so
the
scheduling team mentioned that
when they made their schedule
this year, they took some
of our advice to heart.
And a lot of that,
honestly, was just trust.
I think we had to do a
really thorough job of looking at all
possible metrics that they
thought they might want.
So they didn't say, go
look at x, y, and z.
We thought from our
football background,
what are the possible ways
that anybody out there could ever
see an on-field impact
of these things?
And when we presented,
it was thorough.
It had every possible angle. And
I think because of that approach
where it's saying, like, hey,
we're not going to give you
one thing and say, all right,
we're done. We solved
it. It's going to be,
we're going to give you a
bunch of different ways of looking at
it, a couple of
different outcomes,
a couple different time points.
We're also going to
acknowledge our limitations
and things we don't know.
So for example,
it might not be the case
that teams that are playing three
road games in a row in
the NFL lose more often.
But it is the case that if
you're on a team and you play
three road games, you're away
from your family for three weeks.
And that doesn't just mean that
we can go throw teams on the
road for three, four, or five,
six weeks in a row
because that's going to have other
impacts that maybe
we're not measuring.
So it's not a great answer,
Britney. But honestly, it's just trust.
It's building up a repertoire of
trying to look at a bunch of
different things in a
bunch of different ways.
There isn't--
it's very rare.
I hope for my--
like I said, I
have a great team.
We're almost always
saying, yes. Like,
can you also look at
this? Yep, we'll do it.
Sometimes, maybe it's like,
I don't really think that's
going to matter. But honestly,
it doesn't matter. They think
it matters, so let's go find
out. And so a lot of it is just
sometimes just saying, yep,
we're going to look at every
possible angle and try a bunch
of different things.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: I know that
this hour is always the fastest
hour for me of the week.
So let me rapid fire maybe two
more questions at you, if that's OK.
Well, actually, this is a
quick one. Travis asked,
have you ever lost
in fantasy football?
- Fantasy football
is very noisy.
You could be the best
fantasy football player in the world.
And if you're in a team with
a league with 10 players,
you probably didn't improve
your chances much more from 10%
to 20%. I've lost plenty.
We also have very strict restrictions
about what we can and can't play.
So I'm going to just note that
I used to play it a lot more
than I'm allowed to now.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: I see.
One other question
for you then.
We'd love to hear
what's something that you're most
excited about as you think
about the year ahead?
MIKE LOPEZ : Oh gosh!
Wow!
I think-- RACHAEL
DEMPSEY: It doesn't have to
be the biggest thing.
Maybe it's the first thing that
comes to mind for your team.
-
I think the general state of
football is in a really good
spot. Last year, we had the
lowest margin of victory since,
I think, 1932.
The
game itself, a lot
of the analytic-driven trends--
and I saw a couple of questions
in the chat about these.
Teams are going for it on
fourth down more often. Teams are
coming up with more
creative offenses.
All of that has led to a
more entertaining football.
I mean,
I don't think anybody has ever
turned on a football game and
been like, Oh, this is
going to be awesome.
I can't wait to
see this punt play.
So in general,
the things that are happening
to football is making it more
exciting to watch. And I
do think that that's created--
it's always been
an entertaining product,
but it's really at its
peak. So I think honestly,
the trend for the game
itself is in good shape.
And that,
I think, continues to make
me excited about the season.
It's always the case that
because you have a small sample
size of games,
we have 17 games,
surprises are going to happen.
You're going to see new
teams that weren't in there.
And that's always been
a part of football.
But I just think it's a fun
time to be in a sport where a
lot of the trends
are really improving the entertainment
product of the league.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: Absolutely. Well,
thank you so much, Mike,
for joining us today and
sharing your experience with us
all. And thank you all for
all the great questions.
There were a ton
of questions here.
I'm sorry if we
missed anybody's.
I'll try and go through
and see what we missed.
But have a great rest
of the day, everybody. MIKE LOPEZ
: Thanks. And I left my
email in the chat,
if anybody has any
follow-ups or concerns,
or has a student or a friend
that wants to get into football data.
Please don't hesitate
to reach out.
- That's great.
Thanks so much, Mike.
Have an awesome rest of
the day, everybody Bye.